Speaker 1: I want to briefly talk about Ivanka
Trump. Many of you emailed me about this story.
Ivanka Trump is refusing to be involved with
Donald Trump's 2024 run. Now she is putting a
very positive spin on it there. There's
an article in the cut which summarizes
this called Ivanka would prefer not to. The
article is by Clare Lampe and it was published
yesterday and it includes a transcript of
Ivanka's Instagram post where she said,
I love my father very much. This time around,
I'm choosing to prioritize my young children
and the private life we are creating together
as a family. I do not plan to be involved in
politics. While I will always love and support
my father going forward, I will do so outside
the political arena. I am grateful to have
had the honor of serving the American people,
and I will always be proud of many of
our administration's accomplishments.
Listen, this has been a building fiasco for
Jared and Ivanka. And I have to say, you know,
this isn't about I think Ivanka is great, but it
has always struck me that from the adult children
and I include Jared Kushner in this as the son
in law that Ivanka most accurately had the pulse
had a understood the pulse of what the perception
of Trump and his kids was. And we had numerous
reports when Trump's term was waning and it was,
you know, he had lost already. He was claiming he
was going to figure out a way to stay, but it was
obvious he was leaving. There were these reports
about how Jared and Ivana were struggling with the
fact that their old social circles were refusing.
They were they were not welcoming them back in.
And there were a bunch of different stories that
you can find about this. And then in the lead up
to Donald Trump's announcement on Tuesday night,
there was also reporting about Trump has been
begging Jared and Ivana to be there and it's
not clear whether they are going to be there. And
at the end of the day, if Ivanka wasn't there and
Jared Kushner was, I actually respect this more
than anything I've ever seen Ivanka do. Of course,
she was in way over her head, even being involved
with this administration. She had no business
there. Remember when she sat in for then Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson at like the G something
summit? It's all completely and utterly insane.
But the most responsible and respectful thing that
Ivanka. Has done here is to recognize this was a
humiliation. And, hey, you know what? She values
her personal life. She values her social life. She
realizes that it was humiliating. What happened?
I am sure that she still thinks that good things
were done by her dad. I don't I don't think she
thinks it was a disaster. But she increasingly
recognizes the cartoonish nature of what went on
around the January six riots. There are reports
that Ivanka was horrified by what was going on
and wasn't thrilled with Donald Trump's response.
So I understand why she's not just coming out and
saying this was a complete humiliation to my
my personal family. Right. Her and her kids.
There is probably all sorts of crazy stuff
going on in terms of her versus Jared,
because for now it seems that Jared is standing
behind Trump, although it increasingly seems
like he's not. He would not be a part of in an
upcoming Trump administration. This actually is
the most logical thing I've ever heard of Ivanka
doing. She should have no involvement. It's been a
humiliation. It's been bad for her. It's obviously
terrible for her kids. And this is clearly the
right decision. So good for Ivanka. I think it
makes sense. And the question now remains, what's
Jared going to do on a personal level? I don't
care. But it is interesting to see the difference
between Eric and Don Jr, who are clearly full
speed ahead on this, and Ivanka, who seems a
little bit more reflective and thoughtful about
the disaster that this has been for their family.